I have a problem here from my cousin I
see what it says it says Milwaukee
Wisconsin is directly west of Grand
Haven Michigan on opposite sides of Lake
Michigan so let me draw that so if we
say that this right here say that this
is let's say that right here is
Milwaukee Milwaukee it's due west of
Grand Haven Michigan so if I were to
draw let me draw a horizontal line and
we're going over water so let me do it
in blue so it's due west of Grand Haven
Michigan so there's a horse you know you
go straight east if I were to go to
straight East I would get to Grand Haven
Michigan which is right here Grand Haven
which let me just label that G all right
on a foggy night a law enforcement boat
leaves from Milwaukee on a course of a
hundred five degrees on a course of 105
degrees the hardest part of these
problems in my opinion is is really just
trying to figure out the convention
they're using when they say a course of
105 degrees what does that mean what
direction is it and I checked with my
cousin and her book says that in I guess
in in the boating world the course is
how many degrees clockwise you're going
of due north so due north is zero
degrees so 105 degrees so due north
would be zero degrees due north would be
that's zero degrees and we want to
figure and so he's going 105 degrees
clockwise of that so if we go 105
degrees so he's going 105 degrees so
it's like 100 that's 105 degrees
something like that he's going 105
degrees and I'll do him in magenta his
course is 105 degrees so that's 105
degrees clockwise I'm due north and what
is that oh so my screen just like that
so what is that angle and kind of what
we're familiar well this is would be 90
degrees right here going here and then
he goes 15 more degrees so in kind of
unit circle terms this would be negative
15 degrees or if we wanted to figure out
the angle of this vertex right here that
would be 9 and then we went another
fifteen so the angle this angle right
here this angle right here is going to
be what it's going to be 15 degrees
right because we said his course is 105
so 90 plus 15 is 105 so this this how
much South he's going of kind of you
know straight west East is 15 degrees
right because this whole thing is 100
105 okay let me keep reading the problem
he leaves from the walk in of course of
105 degrees at the same time that a
small smuggling craft steers a course of
195 degrees from Grand Haven 195 degrees
so once again due north is zero degrees
and this guy's going 195 so we're figure
just this is just a convention you
figure out 100 he's going 195 degrees
clockwise of due north so 195 degrees is
going to be he's going to be 180 degrees
and then some it's going to be like that
alright so his course is going to look
something like this his course is going
to look something like that and let's
see if we could figure out what this
angle right here is because we as you
can kind of see where this is going
we're trying to figure out probably the
size of this triangle if I had to guess
I haven't even read the whole problem
yet let's see so he's going 195 degrees
so if we if we if we were to drop go
like here this right here is 180 degrees
to go clockwise from straight up to
straight down this is 180 degree this is
180 and so he went 195 so this is going
to be that's going to be 15 degrees
right and if this angle is 15 degrees
what is this angle going to be
well this entire angle is 90 degrees
right it's kind of the third quadrant
when we're thinking in unit circle terms
so this angle right here is going to be
90 minus this 15 degrees so it's 90
minus 15 it's it's 75 right 75 degrees
95 degrees and if we wanted to convert
his kind of course angles in the unit
circle we could we would have you know
the unit circle you'd start here and you
go all the way around this way so we I
think you would get something like 255
degrees but anyway so we figured out
that this angle is 15 degrees
this angle is 75 degrees what's this
angle going to be on this angle it's
going to be these all have to add up to
180 right so this is going to be 180
minus 15 minus 75 what's that that's 180
minus 90 so 180 minus 90 is 90 degrees
so this angle here is 90 degrees it's a
right angle it's a right angle
interesting okay so what do they tell us
they tell us the law enforcement boat oh
and the law enforcement boat averages 23
knots so he's traveling in this
direction at 23 knots right that's a
little bit faster than 23 miles per hour
and collides with the smuggling craft
what was the smuggling boats average
speed so they both leave their
respective sites at the same time and
they both collide right so kind of the
time they travel is the same lets it
call that time T right I don't know they
both left at the same time it took some
time for them to collide so let's say
that you know the time between when they
left and the time the client is T so how
far did this the the patrol boat travel
well he traveled at a speed of 23 knots
and it took him time T to get to the
collision so the distance he traveled is
23 T 23 T speed times time is equal to
distance so the length of this side is
23 T similarly this guy we don't know
his speed let's call it I don't know
let's call it X his speed is X but the
distance he travels is x times T X times
T right so that's the length of this
side so let's see if we can figure out
what X is so what do we know we know
well we know a lot about this we know
that this is right triangle etc etc we
know this angle so what if we wanted to
solve for X T and use of this 23 T
information let's see we know look at
this angle we if we use the 75 degrees
we know the opposite angle the opposite
side sorry which is 23 T and we know the
adjacent side which is X T
so let me write sohcahtoa here so Toa so
what deals with opposite and adjacent
well that's tangent right Toa so if we
say the tan of seventy-five degrees a
tangent of seventy-five degrees is going
to be equal to the opposite side twenty
three T over the adjacent side
that's the centered opposite over
adjacent XD well the T's cancel out
right the t's cancel out and let's see
if we could solve for X so we multiply x
times both sides you get X tangent of
seventy-five is equal to twenty three
and then divide both sides by the pan of
seventy-five and you get X is equal to
twenty three divided by the tangent of
seventy-five degrees and so that's our
answer and if I had to well actually I
have let's see tangent of seventy-five
degrees I don't have a calculator in
front of me you could calculate it's
going to be it's actually going to be a
pretty it's going to be a pretty high
number so you could try to fit you know
if you have a calculator just type in
seventy-five degrees take the tangent of
it in and perform this calculation but
we've essentially solved this problem
I'll I'll see you in the next video